you're live
chairman thank you very much
burner uh good evening uh and welcome to
this Northwest area planning committee
um on the 10th of January
2024 and belated happy New Year to
everybody I trust everybody had a uh a
good festive season and he's back ready
for The Fray of 2024
my name is councelor Mark
darham and I'm the chairman of this
committee councelor Thompson is now in
the house good evening councelor
Thompson stuck inff that's I'm fine
that's fine members we are streaming
this streaming this meeting live as well
as recording and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded during each item please
put your hand up to indicate if you wish
to speak I will then invite you at the
appropriate time could I ask members to
avoid approaching the top table assist
could create interference with the
cameras and the live stream and please
note that the YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of microphones therefore can I ask
when invited to speak you remember to
turn on your microphone and turn it off
when finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and con prise as
possible and I will add tonight because
of the agenda please don't repeat things
that um have already been stated um item
two apologies for absence uh Miss Casey
have you any apologies
please yes we received an apology forap
from councelor
Sidle but I believe councelor spenley
may also be an apology forap is that
correct councelor Paul spenley councelor
spenley is not a member of this
committee um
Casey no no we we we have two other
counselors that are just in attendance
for your information with have councelor
lagen and councelor Nick spencley
but they are just in an observational
role item three minutes it's recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the six we all right Council yes thank
you 6th of
December found on the pages um I'm sure
you can find them are approved and true
and accurate record I say move do I have
a second thank you councelor Thompson
you are first thank you um members any
points of accuracy on those
minutes nobody is showing
and can we agree by
Ascent everybody happy thank you very
much indeed item four Declarations of
interest interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interest interests other
registerable interests and non-reg
interests relating two items of business
on the agenda having record regard sorry
to paragraph
nine an appendix B of the code of
conduct for members and members you are
reminded that you are also required to
disclose any such interest as soon as
you become aware should the need arise
through the meeting members please show
if you have an
interest no I will declare that I am
currently the chairman of visit Essex
although that is a an other registerable
interest and has no a pecuniary uh
interest um item five uh now um members
I think I've told you all anyway uh that
due to uh public interest in relation to
item six on the agenda I'm going to take
that that
first um which will enable the people
that
are that are here in support of that
application who are occupying the um the
public seats uh they will be able to
leave if they should they wish they can
stay of course um but to allow uh people
that are here for the other items on the
agenda so that moves us neatly round to
um item 6
23920 full Granary chra Farm chra Road
little totm Essex and I think Mrs
Matthews you're taking
this yes um thank you chairman good
evening chairman good evening
members um so this is um an application
at CH farm for the it's a section 73a
application which means it's
retrospective for a change of use of an
agriculture building to a cafe class
euse and provision of associated car
parking I draw memb attention to the
members update which has previously been
circulated which includes HRI par
council's response and further letters
of representation which received since
that was produced there have been um
further letters of support have been
received or put on the system um and
there's a total of 480 letters of
support including those that have
already on on the the agenda and and the
update um a further update is verbal
update is the appc ANS confirmed that
their offer to permanently close the
former restaurant use at the triple Farm
known as The Lodge which is understood
to have closed two years ago as the LOD
is not within the application site it
would not be possible to impose a
condition if plan permission were to be
granted but as the lodge is within the
same ownership as a cafe it will be
possible to secure the permanent
cessation of the use of the lodge as a
restaurant um and having spoken to the
council list earlier today um through
need to be through a section 106
agreement and um and obviously be
subject to the agreement of the
applicant so this is the um slide which
shows the application site boundary
which includes a um the agricultural
former agricultural building towards the
Northern end and the car parking area
towards the South and and also includes
part of chra um of of the road um and
the foot path link that has been created
between the
two
and the cafe itself is on is on the
western side of tricka road and within a
group of buildings including The
Farmhouse and the Eastern side and also
the Eastern side of Cher road which I've
said is on the um is where the car
parking is located the SES in the rural
area outside any settlement boundary
about 1 kmet away as the crow flies from
haybridge and haybridge
Basin this is a proposed block plan
which um shows the again the former
agriculture building at the Northern end
um and in front of there you've got um
the disabled parking spaces and a cycle
store um and then at the southern end
you've got the the car parking area
which is
proposed the the the foot path link is
being created between the two is in with
in the highway Verge and um has got a
hogin type of um surface treatment the
car park is includes around um doesn't
it not around the
um the car parking is 33
spaces these are the elevations of the
barn as was existing um prior to its
conversion and then you've got a layout
there again of the barn prior to its
conversion application relates to about
120 square meters of floor
space these are proposed elevations
which are very similar um to the
existing elevations as were there's been
minimal alterations required to the
building
and then you've got the proposed layout
which includes a seating area prep area
kitchen and
toilets um there's no actual detailed
layout um being provided but it as part
the application stated that up to 40
covers would be available within the um
the cafe um and the propos also includes
an external seating area of around 106
Square met which is directly in front of
the
building and then here are just some
photos just illust purposes so we've got
the converted Barn um you've got the
vehicle entrance to the Courtyard
underneath that and you've got a picture
of the the foot path along the grass
Verge um and then you've got the car
parking area at the southern end of the
site
um in summary it's not considered that
the cafe use proposed is ancillary to
the wide site and certainly based on the
information that that's been provided as
part of the application therefore the
development represents the introduction
of a cafe outside the main towns
Villages and employment areas which is
contrary to policies S8 E2 and E4 the
local development plan furthermore based
on the information submitted apart the
application it's not been demonstrated
that the caffeine meets the needs of
local businesses or the community
therefore objection to the principle the
vomity
raised and I was going to use this
opportunity in anticipation of questions
which may be asked this evening um which
hopefully just be helpful so statut
consult tees have not objected but
comments are limited to their area
expertise which does not cover all of
the material planning considerations
relevant to the application it's
recognized that the proposal to generate
a considerable level of support
particularly since the agenda was
published officers have assessed The
Proposal against the relevant policies
in the in the local development plan and
the mpf and in summary the current the
current ldp policies in particular do
not allow for new Cafe stroke
restaurants to be created in the rural
area unless they are for example um an
inary element of a wider site for
example a cafe to Garden Center or
restaurant within the Caravan Park I.E
one which would be patroned primarily by
customers of the garden center or the
caraman park in the examples that I gave
officers are aware that a number of
leisure and other commercial uses
operated from the farm but there is
insufficient information submitted for
officers to be able to conclude that the
cafe use of the of the size proposed is
ancillary um if the ca Cafe is not incy
there would need to be other material
considerations which would outweigh the
conf with the policies E2 and E4
referred to and policy E2 in particular
aims to protect the viability and
viability Vitality sorry of the
district's Town centers and public and
public support for a cafe is not the
same as there being a functional other
need for the use proposed thank
you thank you Mrs Matthews um we
have
uh I'm not sure how many public speakers
I know we have uh the applicant Mr
Tallow
in Don do we have any other speakers
registered no we've only got one
registered as a supporter but Mr T Mr
twiin would you like to go and take a
seat probably or next to councilor yeah
are there that's fine um Council Morgan
has very kindly put the uh the light on
you have two minutes it is a strict two
minutes I'm afraid um from when you
start to
speak
thank you there has been a restaurant in
operation at chba farm for over 40 years
under planning permission granted in
1982 which coincided with the opening of
chra Fisheries we're not seeking to open
a new restaurant we're just trying to
move the current planning consent from
chra Lodge to a disused agricultural bar
on the other side of our Courtyard if it
must come to a vote on whether the C
Cafe is anciliary to the activities and
businesses at chra then you must decide
objectively who understands this best
either my wife and I who have run this
business for over 20 years as a tourist
destination or a planning officer who
has had limited time no pre application
procedure and an unwillingness to
communicate we can say for certain that
the cafe is ancy and we have 40 Years of
History to prove this the former
restaurant has been closed for two years
now and it's self-evident that it cannot
be considered a viable Alternatives if
we need to write this into a un elateral
undertak of permanent closure then I'm
more than happy to do this planning must
take into account the balance of a
decision in this case there are only
negative consequences of a refusal and
only positive outcomes of an acceptance
a disproportionate weight of objection
has been labored on just one point which
is not equal in weight to the potential
loss of Tourism employment health and
well-being Farm diversification and
overall Synergy of business activities
at chra nowhere in the ldp or nppf does
it state that cafes and restaurants are
exclusively a town center activity this
constitutes a serious misreading and
catastrophic bias furthermore planning
officer has fail to demonstrate that the
Farm Cafe and outside catering business
would be a viable proposition in the
Town Center whereas we've demonstrated
for over 40 years that it is a viable
proposition at chra there is
overwhelming support and from the public
and all the public consulted bodies the
planning officer highlights this in the
report and there are no objections so
please vote in favor of keeping this
popular Cafe at chbr by allowing it
permission to continue to support local
tourism and the molden
district thank you very much indeed um I
received a request from two uh members
of molden District Council um who wish
to speak um and I've agreed that they
can but they will be restricted to the 2
minutes as well and clearly obviously
won't have a vote I'll take them in the
order that they arrived that's councelor
spencley first councelor spenley you
have two minutes as you well know thank
you chair I speak to oppose the
officer's recommendation as councelor
for hybridge East I cannot vote on this
committee as my ward terminates just 500
yards short of the cafe yet in every
sense it is seen as a hybridge asset
it is my belief that the local plan when
conceived was never intended to close
down successful and popular local
businesses especially one such as this
that is the center of a lively and
dynamic local Hub of
Enterprises this recommendation is
completely contrary to the key
priorities of our most recent corporate
plan one supporting our communities
members if you traveled a short distance
down chigur road to the farm Cafe you
will see a facility that is recognizably
part of hybridge whatever notional mark
on the map may say and that is Central
to several major Leisure facilities and
a number of small Enterprises it employs
local people and if I may share a
personal passion it is an inclusive
employer providing supported employment
for adults with learning difficulties
and disabilities through Essex cares
limited a highly rated service working
closely with Essex County Council two
enhancing and connecting our place far
from being some sort of excrescence
ruining the countryside the Farm Cafe
creates a pleasant rural Hinterland for
haybridge residents I do not intend to
linger on this the many messages of
support and appreciation speak for
themselves three helping the economy to
thrive it seems totally illogical to
close a highly successful business
because it's a few hundred yards outside
the town border it is part of a success
story which includes camping fishing
holistic therapies food supply and many
other activities take this away and we
diminish the whole of this much
underrated local club uh hub for a
Greener future of 18 suppliers of food
and products detailed to me five are in
hay bridel molden and the rest are
within a 10mile radius thank you for
listening and thank you chair for
permitting me to speak streamly well
rehears councelor spencley
councelor lagen you're next thank you
chair just like to clarify that I did
put the application in earlier and
called it in uh before publication of
the agenda um but there's a lot this has
been said and been covered already but
just to just to summarize um I don't
call an application in without deep
thought because it's based on planning
is based on policy um this is a farm
calf it's been said that it doesn't
support a High Street or town center
location and it supports and provides
employment preservation promotion uh and
tourism to the area there are other
examples of recent permissions given as
as as Katherine Matthews has just said
within the reasons of refusal policy sa
uh section 2103 seeks to protect the
countryside and recognizes that it needs
to maintain a sustainable rural economy
allow flexibility for development it's
in our own policy this application does
that policy E4 allows for supporting
entrepreneurial activity this proposal
supports the council's own policy and
it's not realistic to to relocate to a
town where would have pressure to
existing businesses as they not in the
same offering the town centers are under
enough pressure anyway and we've just
had a recent um Restaurant close in
molden therefore this offering uh
delivers a functional need and supports
existing businesses as my colleague
councelor spener has said uh with its
development even the mppf itself
supports economic growth in rural areas
it's very clear and in itself has not
enough detail in this report that's
contrary to the nppf and therefore
should be supported policy four and
under Section 4.34 calls for the
diversification of buildings to
Alternative activities and 4.35 also
encourages economic growth in rural
areas this applic satisfies both those
policy needs the application provides
for parking cycling tourism and brings
in thousands of people per anom it
serves local suppliers and local people
it's a far better offering than the old
Lodge with no disrespect um it's it's a
an excellent building the preserv the
conservation officer's report was abely
glowing about the preservation of this
building and I wholeheartedly advise the
members to support this because no
objections are raised if you see page 41
3.22 it's nothing but positive thank you
chair again thank you um councelor lag
and well well practiced members before I
open um to a comment from Northwest
members I just wanted to make a few
points myself because I think seldom
have we had an application that has
generated quite so much public
interest except for the major the major
sites um of course I personally and and
I have declared an interest as being the
chairman of visit ess6 and and on that
basis um and and I'm certainly do not
wish to be seen to be critical of the
officer the officer has looked at this
application and she has assessed it um
in in in line with the policies and has
come to her own
conclusions however um there conclusions
that I'm afraid um I don't agree with in
some respects um I I have an issue uh
with the the fact the statement that
that is not ancillary to an existing
operation um Caravan parts will mention
well this is a camping site a
wellestablished camping site with a
children's playground and glamping pods
so I I I just fail to understand why
this is not ancillary it's been a
tourist destination for a long long time
it is also the host destination for the
Blackwater show which is one of the
major um
events in the district calendar um but
as I said it it there are permanent
camping facilities at the site so I'm
sorry but by definition uh this facility
is ancillary um because if the people
staying in the glamping facilities or
campsite want breakfast where else would
they go which takes me well where would
they go they might go to the tip tree t-
room at OC Island well that's not in a
town either um and we we can cannot keep
we cannot keep making decisions against
rural businesses we know that uh section
88 and 89 of the mppf is based along
planning in favor of the rural economy
and I'm afraid that trumps our uh our
ldp
policies I firmly believe that this
Council should have a can do attitude
rather than a can't do we need to be
support suppor in town businesses and we
need to be supporting rural businesses
and I'm afraid on occasions we haven't
got a good record of either and I recall
certain objections to many applications
in the Town Center as well we made quite
a few of the restaurants jump through
hoops in some cases unnecessarily but
are we going to tell the many many
operations catering operations in rural
areas that they shouldn't be there I
mean I could list many many of them
um and not to mention of course uh the
clemont which uh we were warned on that
night that that would set a precedent
well he here we are again and um I think
anybody that's driven past the site in
wood and Mortimer will have seen that
building and you can be guaranteed that
that when it is open will be certainly
one of the best in Essex and possibly
one of the best of its kind in the east
of England I also find it odd that last
week members would have received a
tourism com uh a tourism report from
Alexis highlighting the importance of
Tourism and I find it bizarre now that
we're going to be looking at a planning
application that actually stifles what
uh we've been told to uh that we've been
told to
um to to determine it's just we just
don't seem to have a joined up approach
so um clearly uh you know I I I have
issues I'm sure that many people will I
hope many agree and I'm sure some will
disagree with some of my points but I
did feel very strongly that uh this
really should be supported and I will
make one other final point and it is
relevant to other
applications is why are we just
restricting rural businesses to have one
catering Outlet if they're big enough
like a like a campsite or a caravan Park
why are we saying you can only have one
catering Outlet certainly the bigger
ones might want a variation so I just
don't see the logic of saying to places
well if you have one you've got to shut
the other it doesn't make any sense at
all if there is adequate demand then
there's adequate demand we should be
supporting it and I've said my piece and
I'm now going to open up to uh to
members I had councelor Morgan first and
councelor white and I'm sure there'll be
others to follow councel
Morgan yeah thank you Mr chairman um
obviously
um I'm required to not be predetermined
in these situations so I have very
carefully over the last few days studied
the officer's uh recommendation the
logic coeny and persuasiveness of it to
see whether it would actually be able uh
to um make me or persuade me against the
very cogent arguments that have been put
forward tonight and I have to say I
failed dismally and therefore uh Mr
chairman can I propose that this
application be approved do I have a
second yes thank you okay thank you very
much thank you councilor Morgan counc
White you were next was a very close run
thing yeah thank you um Mr chairman um
now I've been looking through the
policies here and I'm happy to Second um
councelor Morgan's um proposal you don't
stand I'll and I'll give you the reasons
why um I think we support it because of
policy S1 which is a healthy and
competitive local economy policy S7
which is a prosperous rural economy
supporting rural div diversification and
policy E4 which is Agricultural and
Rural diversification now if we just go
into a couple of these um policies
policy E4 which is the Agricultural and
rural rural
diversification Part B states that it
will contribute to the viability of the
Agricultural business it does it meets
that criteria part C it will not impact
on biodiversity and Wildlife as the
building is already there
4.34 diversification of agricultural
land and buildings is vital to the
viability of many Farm businesses that's
correct at 4.35 the council recognizes
the importance of encouraging economic
growth in rural areas so these are the
policy E4 which for me it meets um
completely then we go on to policy E5
which is tourism under
4.39 the council supports development of
the tourism industry that benefits
tourists and locals well it meets that
development for new tourist facilities
across the district will be supported
this is in our policy map
4.40 we need to remain a competitive
destination and to encourage the growth
of Tourism related sectors under 4.41
viability it has already been proven to
be a viable Enterprise and it states we
will protect rural businesses so for
these reasons I propose this acation
should be approved under policies S1 S7
E4 and E5 which is tourism um thank you
thank you councelor white councelor
Moy thank you chairman
um yeah I mean I've known this site for
years as well and um there is fishing
and there's camping there and I also
think with hundreds of houses that have
been built recently and of course the
Caravan Park and I think its natural in
um expansion and I think with any
business it has to grow you can't just
if you stand still you go backwards and
um I think it's it'll be vital for the
area it'll be good for tourism good for
the economy uh I think it's ideal thank
you thank you councelor moley councelor
Thompson thank you chairman I will be
very brief um for me I have to say you
know we have to take a balanced view of
the policies and for me could you aim
the microphone at your sorry we rely on
it for the YouTube I do apologize um
sorry like the rest of us I have to
balance the policies and give them
weight as appropriate and for me the
tourism and development of the rural
economy Trump's the matter of its being
outside Town Center I'd like to satisfy
every policy but we can't and I support
the motion to to approve thank you thank
you are there any other Ms then I'll let
the off
um Mrs Matthews would you like to
respond to any of those
points
um might be a bit academic but um oh
you're entitled to
your um and one thing I was sorry I was
going to mention at the beginning was I
wanted to publicly thank my colleague in
admin who have processed all these
hundreds of hundreds of letters that
have arrived since the agenda was
published which have had to be dealt
with individually um acknowledged and
let everybody know that the application
is going to committee this evening
um it's been a gigant Gigan effort and
um I just want to acknowledge that
publicly um
so there was a couple of things that I
was going to mention perhaps more from
information than anything else so it
mentioned about whether whether the use
is anciliary or not um to be able to
conclude whether something is ancillary
or not um as officers anyway we would
need a lot more information about how
big the business is that it's going to
be ancillary to um how many customers
are you know how many visitors to triger
Farmers as a as a as an Enterprise um to
be able to judge whether this the size
of the cafe that is being proposed is
ancillary or not because it'd have to be
a small part of the bigger business but
in order to say it is small with any
sort of
um
um yeah with any any sort of conviction
we need more information which isn't in
the application um I think there was a
reference in the applicant made a
reference to there being no
pre-application
discussions but this is a resubmission
of a previous application so it's quite
clear what the issues were last time
most of which have been addressed but
was was this one reason for refusal
which hadn't hadn't been
overcome um there's also been um
suggestions that that the council
shouldn't be um closing down a business
but this is the planning application
whether enforcement action is taken to
actually if if permission is refused
whether enforcement action is taken so
subsequently that's another decision for
another day and um doesn't necessarily
follow um but just thought I mention
that um I'd also wanted to say that
acknowledge that the ldp and the mpf
there are there are elements of both
which would support the proposal so we
know rural Enterprise and businesses and
tourism all those sort of thing yes it
it does but there are other quite
significant polic particular policies in
that ldp that pull in the other
direction and and as officers we are
required to assess proposals based on
the policies that are in the local plan
um and the conclusion that has been
reached I still stand by but that's
based on the policies and assessing that
against the information and the
application has been submitted maybe
there's other information that could
have come in that might may have
resulted in a different
outcome um and the final point I was
going to make is that um there seems to
be this evening quite a quite high level
of disatisfaction with the um the
policies in the ldp and that they aren't
more supportive of of this type of
proposal and maybe that is the Avenue
that members ought to perhaps consider
going down um as part part of the
council is part of the ldp review is
look at that element of the ldp and and
um by sounds of it correct the errors
that that members are finding in in the
policies that that um we are having to
use um current
but um thank you thank you and I totally
appreciate the fact that you know you
made an honest um assessment um and the
only thing I would say in in respect
going back to the point of
ancillary just by looking on their
website it shows the Caravan park it
shows the glamping pods it shows
everything else so I think it
is yeah I I did think about that and I
think my response would be it's not for
officers to go around finding the
information
to put in as part of the application um
yes the information might be there but
but it's up to the applicant and they've
got a professional agent that they've
paid to make their application the only
other I'm sorry I'm going to not I'm not
going to try and be confrontational but
I I have to raise a case that this
committee had at the end of last year in
Wick and Bishops where the planning
officer was engaged at length with the
applic
regarding his initial her sorry her
initial um View and the applicant
basically entered into a horse trading
agreement with the planning officer and
got the planning officer
effectively allegedly to change the
recommendation on the basis that the
percentage of affordable housing was
changed and that in fact when it came to
this committee was the only reason why
the officer made a a positive
recommendation and that's that behind
land behind nine Church Street in Wick
and Bishop so I mean I think
that this a lot of this difficulty might
have been avoided had there been closer
uh communication with with the uh with
the outcome we're going to leave it at
that I don't Mr Johnson I know you want
to say something before we and then I've
got councelor white and then we'll
conclude well it was in
sorry chairman just in support of my of
my of my colleague um I mean I
understand the arguments being made and
the arguments have been made on you know
that there was that there was an
existing building used for the
particular purpose the
same owner occupier I I I I gather um
and that that had contributed to the
rural economy for for a number of years
and you know as officers and as you know
a regular person in in any society we
fully understand that yeah um but when
we're dealing with an application we
deal with what's in front of us and we
deal with the information and any
relevant evidence that the applicant put
in with that
application um where there may be
exceptions against um the the policies
because we we have a set of policies
those policies have to fit a whole range
of different types of applications they
may fit something that may be you know a
Super Source store sized or there could
be something of of these
size so so when we when we apply these
policies we apply them generally in
terms of their principles if there's any
exceptions from the principles these
will normally have to be made by the
applicant and put to us and for us to
then weigh it up in the balance now from
what I understand uh with this
particular application and I am also
aware of the previous application so I
recall when this application came around
around the first time and some of the
issues which have been addressed so I'm
so I'm aware of that those those those
arguments in terms of how this
application um um um would be consistent
with policies on the basis of its
particular merits now talk there was
talk about it being you know part of a a
w a wider Enterprise you know various
operations were talked about in in terms
of how it supports it the particular way
in which it supports it that's not the
basis of how this application was was
was was was was submitted and detailed
for officers to have a full appreciation
of that a lot of what has been said I I
I'm I'm gathering now just from this
from this meeting it may be that had
this had had the application been
submitted and I'm I'm sort of saying
this because there's a bit of criticism
about how officers assess applications
yeah the owners is only the applicant to
do it yeah uh the owners is only the
applicant to to to go through these
processes and detailed why this this
would be either an exception or
consistent with policy in a particular
way if that's not the case it's not for
officers to be making the arguments for
them it's not for officers to be
pointing that out to them so so that's
the base on which we make this applica
this application clar was mentioned I
recall that application we went through
a similar sort of process with that
application at the time then yeah CU if
if we just take the policies in the
blanket sense that some of that has been
made and I have to say that some
comments have been made in in this
committee here you can almost approve
anything in the rural area because you
can then still make the same argument it
supports rural business and it's and
it's a rural Enterprise but that's not
the case you know there's a clear
distinction between Town and Country and
in terms of the type of uses which we
feel whe which the local plan sets out
is appropriate for each and where
there's an exception you need to go
through the processes and that's how we
assess applications thank you chairman
yeah thank you thank you
uh officers we are not being critical I
think Mrs Matthews made a very sensible
point in that it perhaps our ldp is
needs looking at and we certainly need
we need protection in the rural areas of
course we do from from unsympathetic
development but perhaps when we
reviewing the ldp we need to look at the
policies to make sure they align more
with what we want and I'm going to
finish off now councelor white indicated
then I've got councelor Stevens yeah uh
thank you Mr chairman I mean I actually
think that the policy map is very clear
on Rural diversification I mean um E4 is
really clear that it will you know
contribute to the Agri business it will
not impact on diversity and Wildlife
because they are often situated on the
coast which is there this is then they
say it's vital to the viability of many
Farm businesses which it is and I don't
understand where they're saying it's a
small business because as far as I'm
aware they've got I think it's hundreds
of Acres I don't know for sure but then
we're not talking about they're trying
to fit this on a quarter of an acre or
something they are proper Farmers um you
know as one farmer to another we know
everybody farms and they Farm properly
that they're not it's not a small
holding it's a farm um and it and Po and
policy E5 tourism this Council supports
development of the tourism industry I
don't understand how clearer the
policies need to be um so I I actually
I'm I'm surprised that that the
recommendation is there and these are
the same arguments we made for Claremont
and I still think we made absolutely the
right decision here and I'm hoping we
come to a right decision here because I
think this meets the criteria of all the
rural and tourism policies thank you
thank you councelor white well one last
counselor
Stevens thank you chair um I'm going I
can feel myself just ending up
abstaining because I think that what our
policies say are so important but I do
recognize that some policies are met and
as councelor Thompson said maybe you
just can't meet all the policies all of
the time um but I'd like to be very
clear please as to whether we are going
to impose a condition that the uh I
think it was called the gra the old
restaurant anyway um are we going to
impose some sort of condition that that
must never be a restaurant again um
because that that could increase the
number of covers to about 65 I think
which does seem a lot and doesn't seem
just ancillary to me um is that for
members to decide councelor stev well I
I would propose that we do then we
already have a proposal and and I will
ask the proposer of that whether we wish
whether you wish to request a unilateral
undertaking or a or a section 106
agreement no Mr chairman I don't I'm
sorry no Mr chairman I do not so your
proposal is to just grant this without
any restrictions is that your agreement
with that councelor Mr
White okay so the proposal on the table
is that this application is granted
without a restriction on the ex on the
previous which the owner has said is not
viable and we take the owner but I
you've you've heard My Views anyway but
that is the proposal on the table we'll
now take a vote by means of a show of
hands those in
favor
those
against that is carried so that
application is granted thank you
chairman could I sorry yes could I ask
whe there's any particular conditions
that members would like to see attached
to uh the the the stand well it's
difficult because it's retrospective
isn't it so I don't think
um the time limit is is obviously not
okay no so there' be the the drawing
numbers um I was just wondering whether
on this issue of
um they're tying the use somehow to the
tri of farming in being ancillary or um
well I think we're going to run into
danger if we're saying it can only be
used by
customers okay all right I just don't
think that it isn't being used only by
customers now so I don't think it would
be reasonable to no okay I just thought
I'd ask a question while um while it
customers from a wide wide area natur
standard this the standard thank you
thank you very much
indeed
um members we're just going to wait and
get the other gentlemen in who've been
very patiently waiting thank
you sorry chairman can I just clarify
that the conditions will be agreed in in
uh discussions with the with the
chairman and offic correct correct yes
yes thank
you okay so thank you m MERS um I hope
you don't mind me taking that out of
order but as you can see that there was
a a considerable amount of
interest uh so the next item on the
agenda tonight um is uh
23894 land adjacent to Oakland's kelvan
Road great
totam um who's taking us through this
one I'm going to take you my chair okay
yeah thank you
okay this application is for the
erection of four dwellings with
Associated garages and alterations plus
the extension of the existing access and
provision of parking spaces to Pippins
two dwellings would be detached and the
remaining two SE detached the site was
recently granted planning permission on
appeal this is a plan of the approved
scheme this followed the non
determination of an application for the
erection of four dwellings this is a
material consideration of significant
weight as this is a simpler scheme in
terms of dwelling numbers and general
layout minor changes are proposed to the
access layout and the incorporation of
the garage to Pickins and additional
parking
spaces this is the proposed site
plan and this is just a closeup of the
proposed changes it's proposed to
convert the garage into an office
motorcycle or cycle store the internal
layout of the garage remains unchanged
however the garage door would be
repaced condition three of the proposed
permission would ensure the building
remains as incidental to Pippins the
will connect with two spaces located to
the side of the
building here are the elevations one and
two and the floor
plans here are the elevations for three
and
[Music]
four and again floor
plans and here are the plans and
elevations for the proposed single and
double
garages this is the proposed Street
Scene and here are some photographs of
the
site this is the view of the existing
access which would be
extended this is a view of the existing
garage to serve Pippins and the parking
would be to the there next to the
boundary this is a view from the site
looking back towards the highway and to
the existing residential development at
celv
Road this is a view of the site in the
context of the residential development
and the country
side and this is a view of the site
itself um members will notice that some
works are taking place um this is with
regard to the previously approved
application um the applicant has sought
to discharge the only pre-commencement
condition imposed on this permission
which was for the submission and
approval and writing of a construction
method statement conditions 35 and 14 of
this permission are currently being
considered by the local planning
Authority matters of the position of the
site outside of a def settlement
boundary were considered and found
acceptable by the inspector due to its
close proximity to the boundary
furthermore the inspector found no harm
given the Eastward extension of built
for
given its location existing landscape
and that it's not readily visible at
kelv Road and is only Apparent from the
public footpath the site's present
character clears the domestic Garden
land the only harm well aside from the
building works the only harm found by
the inspector is that the proposal do
not Accord with the prevailing pattern
of development of which in the planning
balance the inspector afforded little
weight due to the sustainability
credentials of The Proposal it is
therefore recommended that Planning
Commission is
granted thank you yeah thank you very
much indeed we have one public speaker
Mr Jackson I understand who's the agent
Mr
Jackson find a seat with a microphone
make yourself
comfortable um and then press the the
button on the
microphone on the bottom there y yep
there's a button Council that's it and
then uh you have two minutes from when
you commence speaking thank you
thank you chairman and good evening
members I'm a charter Town planner and I
am instructed by mab Building Solutions
Mr Harding to my right is here this
evening he's a director of the company
and owner of the house oaklands which
joins the application site site was the
subject of a previous planning appeal to
the Secretary of State and received
planning permission on the 27th of March
2023 planning permission was granted for
the erection of two four-bedroom houses
and two three-bedroom houses in and semi
detached form access was approved from
kelvon Road along an existing driveway
which serves the public foot path and
the residential dwellings Pippins and
oaklands this application seeks a minor
revision to widen the approved access
way this also includes a slight
realignment of the road Pippin's garage
is to be converted and two parking
spaces are shown to the side of the
existing
garage overall the revisions will
improve access for Refuge vehicles and
fire operators who will turn in the
proposed turning head between plots 2
and three also for any other vehicles
who may be passing along the axess road
at a similar time and to provide more
room for pedestrians and users of the
for
path the proposals amount to a material
change requiring planning permission
however the changes are minor the
planning considerations remain the same
as that considered by the inspector in
the determination of the appeal the
slight increase in hardened surfaces
will make no difference
to the character and appearance of the
area the access will be an improvement
to that already granted planning
permission we note that there have been
no res residents representations that
Wick and bishop's Parish Council have no
comments to make and there is no
response from great totam Parish Council
's County Council highways Authority
have no objections and there are no
objections from any other
consules the officer's recommendations
is to approve and the application with
conditions and revised Construction
management conditions set out in your
members
update we therefore invite the council
to Grant pling commission thank you
Mr thank you members councilor
white um thank you Mr this is uh really
just an observation I mean if it's been
allowed appealed we have um you we've
got to go with with the appeal decision
but I think partly it's the reason for
appeal I'm a bit concerned with because
the appeal says it's for the um non
determination between the prescribed
time um and failure to give notice and
this seems to be happening um quite
frequently so could officers tell me why
it wasn't determined when it should have
been
determined good question I suspect it
was a long time ago knowing how long it
takes to get an appeal but well that
that that can partly be the
case March 23 so 10 months
ago yeah that that's not uncommon
that's not uncommon but there be that
Gap that distance I mean if there's a
non-determination then there's a there's
a there's a right to to appeal against
um uh the non-determination for the
applicant who may or may not choose to
do
so so it may just have been a day a day
it may just have been a day or two over
the the the date give looking at this no
we didn't well well if there's an appeal
and we have haven't made a decision then
we can't then make a decision no and no
but the point councilor white is asking
is why we didn't manage to make the
decision in the prescribed time
initially that's that's not really
something that can be discussed at
committee okay that's not really a
committee matter I'm not sure why that's
been I'm not sure why that's been asked
well because it's be coming up a lot
lately but it's not a matter for
determination as to off no no no I no
but I think it's I don't think it's Mr
the chair of one of the officers I think
was Greenwood
yeah um I raised my hand it's actually
unrelated to the matter raised by
councelor white I didn't actually deal
with the application previously so I I
can't answer that question um but um
this is with regards to the members
update I just wanted to check that my
sound keeps dropping in out so I just
wanted to check that members were aware
that there was an update and this is
just with regards to condition five
which is a pre- commencement condition
for construction management plan um we
haven't actually received comments back
from C consules however the plan is
exactly the same as the one approved the
previous scheme saved for the hours of
operation um which were actually
suggested in the condition any way and
have been satisfied so the wording of
that condition is proposed to be changed
just to ensure that the management plan
is implemented rather than one is
submitted again thank you chair
okay thank you Miss White yeah coun
white and just to confirm that um it's
I'm quite happy with the fact that all
the consult tees haven't responded
because obviously that's quite common um
and I just wanted to raise that point as
well thank you okay thank you councelor
Tompson um thank you chairman um I
propose we agree the officer's
recommendation if I second
that any other members wish to speak on
this before we come so we have a
proposal accept the officer's
recommendation duly seconded those in
favor please
show thank you very much that is
granted uh we now come to item seven on
the agenda
23952 n Cherry Blossom Lane cold Norton
Pages 51 to 66 I think that's you miss
Greenwood
again
um L you're
muted oh yes you are Miss Greenwood
you're on
again thank you that's okay um this
application is for nine Cherry bom Lane
and is for the erection of two Bungalows
with off street parking and private
imunity
space the site is located on the Eastern
side of cherry blossom L just outside of
the second boundary of cold Norton which
runs along the southern edge of the site
application currently comprises of
grassland immediately adjacent to the
south of the site is number seven Cherry
bom Lane and detached B below to the
north is the Garden area known as poers
The Proposal follows a previous
application from 2017 which thought
Planning Commission for the erection of
a bung this was refused by order
District Council but allowed it appeal
Planning Commission was also granted by
this Committee in February 2023 for the
tion of a three
bung this PR represents a REV scheme
following a refusal of planning
permission at the site in July 2023 for
the erection of two Bungalow including
parking this was a delegated decision
and the application was refused o to the
harm caused to the residential Amun of
the neighbor to the south at number
seven
Cherry the current application seeks to
overcome the reason for refusal by
introducing a 2 met high fence along the
southern boundary and a 1.8 m High close
boarded fence on the shared boundary and
parking area this would prevent views
into the private me to space of number
seven from bedroom 3 of plot two it
would also prevent overlooking from the
kitchen and Lounge of the proposed
Bungalows here is a floor plan of the
proposed Bungalows obscure glazing has
been introduced to theway and
bathroom here are the
elevations and this is the cycle
store here are some photographs of the
site this shows the site from the
highway and from the private track
that's the track there with the site
just here to the
right and this is a view of number seven
and a view of their driveway and their
imunity
space the planning history for the site
is a material consideration whilst the
site is outside of the de development
boundary and thus in principle the
development is contrary to the policies
in the development plan which seek to
direct new residential development to
established settlements the development
site ABS the settlement boundary and
based on the inspector's previous
comments and previous committee decision
the principle of development has been
found to be acceptable and the
development will be accepted in terms of
design and impact on the area there have
been no technical or neighbor objections
received it should be noted that the
proposal is only deemed acceptable if
the boundary treatments are erected and
remain in place and a condition is
suggested and posed in this regard it is
therefore recommended that Planning
Commission is granted thank you
chair uh thank you very much and indeed
we have no public speakers I have three
members uh in order that is councelor
Morgan then white and then my oh I'm
sorry okay right councelor councelor
Miss White I'll let you go first thank
you Mr chairman uh yeah I actually
called this to committee because
although it went through appeal um the
problems I raised during the first time
it was refused um were still relevant
until some time ago and they were
basically that the parish council
residents has spent a lot of money
tarmacking the road and as I I fully
understand it's not a planning matter um
but I I thought that the applicant would
be reasonable and in fact he has worked
I have now heard that he has worked with
the parish council and he is going to
not only look after the newly tarmac
Road um he is actually going to extend
it to cover the houses so a lot of the
objections I had although they weren't
planning reasons have actually been
resolved but I wanted to make sure they
were resolved and that's why I called
the committee and I only heard this
evening from the Paris Council that they
were really happy um so yeah so I would
like to say that I actually do now
support the um Council the officers
recommendations to approve this
application and I'm happy to propose
that we accept them thank you councelor
Morgan oh I just
second
Thompson thank you chairman I was going
to say given the um planning history I
happy to agree I was going to make the
proposal that we agreed already made
Thompson but so we have a any other
members wish to speak no members we have
a proposal to agree the officer
recommendation to
approve that are with the condition
suggested by the officer which is in
relation to the boundary treatment yes
those in favor please
show thank you that is
agreed and the last item on the agenda
tonight
night uh we now have uh 23 SL
013 land at hfield House whtm Road
little
braad uh who is taking us through this
one oh sorry yes M Bradley Miss Bradley
yes thank you chair good evening
members sorry just got to find out how
do we how do we move it
on
turn off okay just
click yeah okay yeah thank you apologies
members let me just get back to where I
was right good evening this application
is is des described as a change of use
of an ancillary storage shed Workshop
into a key worker family dwelling
alterations to the out building also
include changes in terms of material and
fenestration the site is on the Northern
side of witon road opposite s's Farm the
site is outlined in red on this plan
with the applicants ownership also
outlined in
blue the site is accessed from with Road
using the existing
access and it includes HomeField house
which is in the northern part of the
site there are two buildings that you
can see in the southern part of the site
the larger one is used for garaging and
workshop use and the other smaller one
immediately to the south of it is the
subject of this
application GS Howard transport owned
and operated by the applicant operates
from the site the Reed Bakery also on
the applicant's ownership and operation
Operation is adjacent to the site and
outlined in in blue in the
application there's a large gravel hard
standing area which has access from
whittam Road and that provides parking
and maneuvering space for the various
uses plan um for the building at the
moment it's just a single story
structure um the applicants were propos
to insert a floor so that there's living
accommodation on the ground ground floor
with potentially a third bedroom and on
the first floor would be two bedrooms
and on suite and
bathroom these are the existing
elevations the building's pretty much
staying as it is externally just with
some changes um which are shown here in
terms of fenestration and materials
these are considered to be
acceptable just running through some
photos now this is the view of the site
um looking into it from Road and you can
see the the subject of of this
application the building in the
background there and this is just
another one showing the entry into the
site and in the gravel hard standing
area again this is just the existing
building which is to be converted the um
the the small lean to on the side of the
building is to be demolished as part of
this
application again just another view of
the building this is the elevation where
the the front door the building would be
so again it's changes to fenestration um
on this
elevation and this is another view with
the the subject building on the right
hand side and a view towards HomeField
house um towards the the rear of the
photograph
there and just another one of the the
building with the the larger building
that I mentioned before to to the
rear just in terms of um the the
application as set out in the report the
s is located outside any defined
settlement boundary and is in the
countryside for planning
purposes the impacts from design
character of the area highway safety
amenity impacts are all considered to be
acceptable however the site has some
distance from settlements and safe
access cannot be provided for
pedestrians and cyclists to the nearest
settlements due to the narrow roads and
the lack of
footways also the site's not well
located for public transport
therefore occupants of the site would
rely heavily on the use of the car to
fulfill their day-to-day living
requirements the applicant is willing to
enter into a section 106 agreement to
tie the dwelling to the host dwelling
home field house however this wouldn't
mitigate the harm of the new dwelling in
the countryside um in an unsustainable
location whilst the
applicant while the applicant's son and
daughter-in-law would live in the
dwelling and also work on the site they
cannot be considered to be key workers
which is how the application is
described going on the the necessary
Financial contribution towards the Essex
Coast Rams has not been secured however
the applicant has confirmed they're
willing to enter into a section 106 to
secure
this accordingly the application is
recommended for refusal for two reasons
thank
you thank you Miss brandley um I think
we have one public speaker Mr
Richardson good evening Mr Richardson
take a seat you've heard the routine
yes and you have two minutes from when
you start to
speak just one second we get the your
time ready okay thank you good evening
chairman and members of the planning
committee I've been asked to say a few
words Mr Howard and family in respect to
the plan application submitted for the
change of use of the story shared and
workshop within the grounds of HomeField
house to a legally tied residential two
bedroom property an earli application of
works of a similar nature was withdrawn
following constructive feedback received
from senior planning officers a fresh
submission was prepared with an emphasis
on trying to meet the controls of the
adopted plan with special regard to
policy S1 that sets out to achieve high
quality sustainable development the
conversion of the existing established
and substantial outbuilding should not
aversely affect the character of the
area its immediate landscape or c any
nuisance or overlooking any neighboring
properties the design and conversion
been informed by the many recent
successful completed schemes within the
district where buildings of a similar
nature such as class Q Farm barn
conversions can comfortably create
modest
accommodation the proposal should not
creating material change to the
Landscaping of the site and policy
compliant parking Garden area and Living
Spaces afforded with the design a key
point of the success of the scheme is
its sustainable relationship with the
host dwelling and both Family Bakery and
neighboring business activities the H
business allowing the proposed residents
the ability to live adjacent to their
places of work thus reducing commuting
on the roads otherwise the proposed
residents will be forced to seek
accommodation elsewhere in The Wider
area the volunteering the section 106
agreement should ensure the legal
relationship between the host dwelling
and the new property be secured by way
of a formal agreement the applicants
have endeavored to secure the necessary
paperwork to comply with the provision
of the checking and monitoring fee for
Rams which they're only recently made
aware of and are in the process of doing
so the accommodation provides several
benefits and will assist in the
development of the work community and
Leisure facilities within the site and
also creates a neutral effect on the
local road infrastructure because of the
travel movements that currently Prevail
in
commuting we fully recognize the
judgment is delegate and finally
balanced but we ask you kindly respect
the genuine nature of this proposal
which allows two valued members of the
working community in little braad to
reside in the parish in an affordable
manner which meets their needs and
hopefully the needs of generations to
come thank
you very much indeed councelor Morgan uh
yeah thank you Mr chairman obviously
I've I've called in this this
application um I have to say I'm um
again obviously I do not supposed to be
predetermined on this and looked again
at the officer uh reasons for refusal I
am disappointed I'm particularly
disappointed that uh no mention uh was
made of policy S7 which ex states that
the council actively seek to support and
facilitate sustainable Economic
Development within the villages through
the vision of live work units and small
and micro business space the support and
enhancement of rural diversification
tourism Leisure opportunities also uh I
would
um ask the consideration be given to um
number 89 of the nppf which I will quote
from saying planning policies and
decisions should recognize that sites to
meet local business and Community needs
in rural areas may have to be found
adjacent to or Beyond existing
settlements and in locations are not
well served by public transport in these
circumstances be important to ensure the
development is sens to its surroundings
does not have an unacceptable in impact
on local roads and exploits any
opportunities to make a location more
sustainable which this will do um and I
would also point out the fact that the
business of the use of car this is as
people most members will know is beside
the braad bakery which is very well
served gets a considerable amount of uh
of of people driving there um and there
also in fact there's also a transport uh
uh company based there so U and in fact
what this this um this application uh if
approved will do will
actually stop as the the agent has
pointed out the requirement for the the
um son and daughter-in-law the applicant
to actually have to go out and drive to
and from their place of work um and
finally just a sort of it I have
frequently both walked and cycled down
the road to that particular site and
therefore uh Mr chairman I propose that
this application be approved do I have a
second thank you very much indeed M
Bradley did you want to respond to
councelor Morgan thank you chair um I I
think in terms of coming back to um
reference to policy S7 and and policy 89
that the reason they aren't specifically
included as I didn't think they were
particularly relevant um they deal with
rural diversification and economy and
this is a dwelling in the countryside
and there there's no evidence to justify
that that dwelling is needed for either
of the businesses that operate on the
site um so that's why that they weren't
considered
um in terms of no need to commute that
that is acknowledged however it's still
a dwelling in the countryside and they
would need to leave the site for for
other uses I think as I've mentioned in
the report whether they need to go
shopping or to doctor surgeries School
drop off that sort of thing so it it
doesn't negate the the need to travel
from the site thank
you okay I just say I I was beg to
differ in terms of the weight we G on
that ases you're right I I won't State
the obvious and say that there is also a
cafe in a rural area that isn't actually
ancillary to anything um but anyway
we've left that one uh behind so unless
there are any other comments from
Members we have a proposal the name of
councelor Morgan seconded by councelor
Miss White to approve this application
contrary to the officer's recommendation
those in favor please
show those
against one
abstain and that is carried so that
application is granted thank you very
can
Poli there a section section 106
time thank you I'm sorry
yes us condition will be delegated to
offices in consultation with the
chairman yes that's fine M Coy yes thank
you thank you thank you very much indeed
thank you very um next item on the
agenda any other items of business the
chairman of the committee decides are
Urgent you'll be glad to hear I have
none please members do not enter into
any discussion about tonight's business
have a safe journey home see you all
soon thank
you